bootleg C
exclusive Power 98.3 where hip hop lives
man bootleg Cav on the phone right now
this dude is being talked about a lot we
have got 40 Glock what's up man yo yo
what is zoo man I'm just chilling
brother uh so uh a lot of controversy uh
let's see two days ago or the night
before last I guess um video comes out
of you and the game um the game filming
on his iPhone like you guys get into a
skirmish um there's been a new video
that has came out and and and you know
what what's your side of the story cuz
you know from from the consumer side it
just kind of looks like game was just
you know kind of punking you a little
bit so what what what really went down
what didn't we see I mean you it's
obvious what you know nobody everybody
know I don't go out like that you know
what I mean I'm I'm obviously held down
at gunpoint you feel me so you know it
it is what what it is and you know I got
jumped all that footage is edited I got
jumped like three times you know they
spliced up footage of the edit they they
made sure they was cutting everybody out
that was jumping but if you look at it
you see you see the feet you see the
people they was clipping the scenes you
know what I mean audio editing it it was
all good but the whole thing is it was a
jump you know what I'm saying so
previously to to what was filmed you had
gotten jumped yeah I got jumped you know
what I mean I was just put in a
situation I mean it's street it's Street
stuff so you know dealing with Street
stuff you just got to take it as what it
is but it's Stu it's not Street stuff no
more when you taking it and you want to
go make it V to try to boost your image
like you punking somebody because he
know that in my natural state like when
I when I was ready to fight back they'll
rush me again like what you don't see on
the camera is when is like I'm ready
like like I'm like y'all jumping me you
know what I mean I said clear as day
that's what he forgot to edit out on the
footage so and I and I said it and then
I was still when I was ready to fight
right then they rushed me from the side
see the cameras look like oh he just
swinging on me it was all of them
swinging on me right there you know what
I mean so you know it was just like it
is what it is you know they did a lot of
lot of uh editing with the they was
taking out the dude's voice you know
everybody talking about pop him pop him
now let me pop him you know what I'm
saying so I it was really nothing I
could do with that you know what I mean
but like far as far as the streets he
took it from being Street when he took a
V and tried to use it for to boost his
image like he punking somebody so you
know it ain't no it ain't no it ain't no
presses no no filing charges on them and
all that ain't nobody pressing no
charges I was just like give me a fair
one give me a head up a one1 you know I
I I fight you all day I was solo by
myself I'm like damn you big as hell
let's let's me and you could just scrap
what is everybody jumping me for okay
let me ask you this uh what what was the
situation that transpired like cuz of
course you and game have had had your
issues uh o over Twitter you and
everybody from Black Wall Street if I
mean you know I'm I'm I'm close friends
with a lot of the dudes over there um
you guys have had your your known issues
what what was the situation what was the
circumstances of of what happened I mean
how did y'all run into each other I mean
we was all we was in a pool party
together you know he didn't want no funk
in there I'm like I'm I'm here I was
right there we was looking dead at each
other and you know so it was that type
of party it was like it ain't popping n
d you know dudes wait till leave the
cars just way down it's like the cars is
like a mile away it's some hills I'm
exaggerating when I say a mile away but
it was it was like that was about that
far so you couldn't get to the cars cuz
you couldn't Park up at the Mansion pool
party you know what I mean so as I'm
walking you know I turn around and I
when I turn around I hear everybody
talking behind me screaming like turn up
I turn around it's me I'm like what's up
everybody running and me with guns so
there was some guns for sure 100% but
I'm saying like if we going to do it
like this what what's the guns for like
and you were you were Doo you went to
this party by yourself yeah you know
what I'm saying I Swang in there you
know what I mean I I mean if anybody
know fo and they know FY Glock they know
I roll I I I don't care if I roll solo
if I got 10 people with me I'll roll
like that like I'm I'm a man at the end
of the day I handle mine you know what I
mean I fights I does whatever I'm not I
don't fear no man you know what I'm
saying so at the end of the day I was
just put in the situation and dealing
with Street stuff you know that it's
it's not it's not something different
that what he did what what he did is
that it it was what what happened if you
going to keep it real just put the real
out there you know what I mean because
that was something he shouldn't have put
it out there if he didn't want the real
to be out there you feel what I'm saying
like you recorded it but you edited it
all up to make it look like you was one
man in me and punking me you know what
I'm saying and that wasn't the case
because every time I was ready to get
down I got a pistol pointed at me you
know what I'm saying and I'm like what
what what what is this okay let me ask
you this and seven and 10 dudes on let
me ask you this from cuz like when I
first watched the video you know I heard
like in the background I heard dude
saying like Chuck Chuck fall back fall
back now just from like an Outsiders
perspective it it sound like if if they
were jumping you now this is just from a
third party perspective not saying what
what I feel whatever but if they were
jumping you why I mean wouldn't they
encourage him to hit you as opposed to
trying to get him not to hit you they
tell him to fall back now because it was
people coming around so let me ask you
this cuz cuz there was a a part in the
video where where he was like like you
was squared up exactly no you talking
about where I was yeah I was spining
square up and then they rushed me on the
side and that part's not on camera that
part not on camera it's on camera they
got the camera it's other camera footage
but it was all of them so you got 15
dudes and they all it's all of them with
their cameras what they doing is they
editing out all the footage of the dudes
jumping me and they editing out if you
look at the whole videos when when the
video Start yo I had a hat on I wear a
hat you know what I'm saying I ain't got
no hat on right there I was already
jumped now F like did you get any cuz
cuz physically like like I mean cuz I I
from the I mean look it was iPhone
footage so it wasn't the clearest
footage in the world but from the little
bit of footage that game put out from
his phone it see it didn't seem like you
were physically harmed as much I mean
what what kind of wounds did you get
from you know as as far as all that that
ain't nothing I'm like I brush it off I
brush it off I'm ready for the next day
I'm a trooper but I'm just like if you
going to keep it 100 I mean he want to
he want he want my Street Credit you
feel me is if he playing he want to play
the a a a weird game like I said what
they doing this chess not Checkers you
know what I'm saying like he want to
play he want to act like he playing
chess but really he playing checkers you
feel me so at the end of the day you you
you you playing with footage and you
taking Street you taking real Street
stuff and you trying to take it out
there and play with it like if you if
you wanted to keep it silent and keep it
Street this should have been left like
that I told him that while they was
doing it I was like this ain't this
ain't for no internet this ain't for
nobody I was like this this
us you know what I mean okay so they
want it to be us it's cool though you
know what I'm saying I'm like I I ain't
tripping I'm just I'm cool you feel me I
I you see me I'm laughing it off up in
there I'm like okay that's how you get
down okay you know you hear like fairies
it's all good I can accept this you know
what I mean what what is what was your
initial like what are the initial issues
that you I mean your history with game
just so everybody know was it does it go
back to the gunit [__] or I mean you
know far as all that I I don't I don't
um I I don't try to I don't involve I
don't involve 50 in my in my quarrels
you feel me I don't I don't involve my
homies in my quels you know what I'm
saying I don't press dist stress buttons
or none of that I don't do that you know
what I mean like I said that's why they
C me solo like that I I roll solo I I
don't care about rolling solo okay so
what do you what do you have to say to
the people me let me just ask you this
like I said man cuz a lot of like a lot
of the the internet you know people who
watch who watch this [__] online and the
people you know everybody comes up with
their own own conclusions of what they
think happened you know game went on his
Twitter saying what you're saying is is
a lie and well if I'm a lie then put the
whole footage out why is it edited where
my hat where my hat ain't on okay so
what do you h i mean what do you have
cuz from know what he hiding he hiding
he wanted to look like he was solo and
they didn't jump
cuz it's almost like there's a certain
point of the part of the part of the
movie where it's like yo why you know
you could have game went out there he
put it out there that I got knocked out
for one when he put out the footage I
wasn't knocked out still standing still
doing me for two he put on there that he
beat me up that he beat me up or he and
he did this solo that's why the footage
is at it because it'll clear as day show
everybody else jumping in and jumping on
me you know what I mean and that's why
it ain't it it just clips into where him
standing right there they got all the
footage they have it they have it of
course they going to take that out they
don't want to show the reason why and if
they was just jumping me and it was just
them jumping me I still fight back right
so what let me ask you that why I didn't
fight back that's my next question I was
going to ask you there seemed like to be
a couple of points where you could have
fought back a little bit but it it it
didn't seem like you really you did from
a little from the footage that we see is
there a reason why you didn't fight back
or it's the whole reason why I didn't
fight back I just told you I'm getting
jump and I'm getting jump at gunpoint
you can't fight be is a street smart
dude you walk away from that you got to
you got to accept that because if you
take off on the wrong person and you
press the wrong button when when them
person somebody life would have pop you
and then it wouldn't the camera footage
wouldn't have never came out so if I
would have got shot it wouldn't have
been no camera footage that's right you
ain't lying so I mean look man you got
to learn you got to be street smart and
you got to be conscious and tell
yourself okay this ain't nothing it
ain't nothing it ain't nothing we know
what time it is you know this happened
every day on the streets he left in the
streets he didn't want to leave it in
the streets so you know I'm I'm just all
I'm doing is I'm just telling it how it
is you know he want to you want to
assassinate my street credit and my and
and my uh uh uh my my my my whole image
of me you know what I mean you can't do
that with a real dude real recognize
real you know what I'm saying so at the
end of the day you 65 I'm five I'm 5'9
let's we could chunk them you know what
I mean I I don't size ain't nothing well
hey man well I guess you know it's just
kind of up to everybody out there to
believe whatever side they want to
believe man um hopefully you know more
footage comes out to kind of like you
know help that footage ain't coming out
he don't want that footage out there he
don't want that out there cuz he going
to look like a sucker it was a sucker
move you know what I mean so at the end
of the day it is what it is you know I I
mean I was slipping but me slipping
don't mean I won't fight that's the
whole thing like I fight I will fight
that's what I don't do I'm I'm with the
full get down active you know what I me
did you did you get to did you get any
any any shots in at all that that
weren't shown on camera N I didn't swing
at all I couldn't swing I didn't swing
at all I didn't do no I didn't do it was
no it was no confrontation for me cuz
I'm like man I can't do nothing yeah you
don't you don't when somebody got a gun
and you can't get that gun from I
couldn't even just take if I would have
just tried to take one gun you got like
three or four other ones that's going to
pop pop me up so I'm like you know I'm
in a situation where you just got to
like you know here you got to do yeah
you got to take your licking sometimes
you just got to take that L take that
one ain't nothing you know what I mean I
walk away from that that ain't nothing
yeah sometimes you in a situation you
just got to take that L yeah so you know
I mean I got to give I got to give the
the uh the the the biggest the biggest
dummy award for recording and editing
the video the biggest dummy award goes
to the game well I hope y'all all get
this settled you never want to see no
violence you know I'm real tight with
with with a lot of dudes in Black Wall
Street and uh it just I would hate to
see it end ugly for anybody involved
exactly man ain't no violence man you
know to me man I mean you know I'm doing
me man the album is in stores New World
agenda I just dropped Cesar mavelli it's
out so you know everybody can check that
out you know good music you know see
what it is man